cet engagement marque le fait de bloquer
des terrains à l'extérieur du site pour
environ une vingtaine d'hectares
ainsi qu'une trentaine d'hectares sur le
site lui-même pour compenser les
constructions qui vont se dérouler sur
le centre d'entraînement pour sa
création l'objectif est de dédier des
zones donc à l'extérieur du site mais
aussi sur le site à la biodiversité à
eau pour garantir qu'un certain nombre
d'espèces faune et flore vont pouvoir
continuer à se développer sur le site ou
proches du site dans les yvelines
c'est donc un engagement de 30 ans qui
se régularise ce soir entre le paris
saint-germain et bio d'ifd pour la
gestion pour l'identification d'abord
puis la gestion pendant trente ans de
ces différentes zones
nous avons aussi d'autres sites qui ont
été identifiés grâce à la région ile de
france et qui seront gérés par par
l'organe de la région ile de france
dédié à gérer ces sites
la totalité de ces deux éléments ce qui
composera auto d'un total de 54 ha 20
hectares en 2h24 éclat en dehors du site
et 30 hectares sur le site